maurice bejart chef bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur rtl france pour
parler de cette transformation de la
cathédrale notre dame de paris ou de sa
rénovation précisément certains
architectes disent que ça va ressembler
à disneyland est ce que c'est votre avis
alors je n'ai pas personnellement eu
entre les mains le dernier dossier en
date concernant la rénovation de
notre-dame de paris mais je comprends
les autres les inquiétudes de certains
architectes dont maurice pilot est de
mon point de vue il est essentiel de se
conformer au cahier des charges
clairement définis sinon les multiples
expertises consultation et audit sur les
lieux il préconisait une remise à son
état d'origine
de la cathédrale afin que cette dernière
retrouve en fait toute sa dimension sa
splendeur patrimoniale la boule tant
bien même dans sa dimension
architecturale
story coulé et spirituelle d'ailleurs
vous profitez en parallèle de cette
rénovation ou modernisés l'édifice là où
il en avait besoin particulièrement en
ce qui concerne l'aspect sécuritaire et
éventuellement
concerne son exploitation touristique
c'est tout à fait louable mais
sans doute indispensable parfois mais si
cette mondialisation entraîne comme ça a
été cité la mise au rebut d'oeuvre tels
que des statues des hôtels le dessin
d'où leur dessein de deux nouveaux
vitraux etc il faut immédiatement revoir
mais décrit l'exécution de ce genre de
d'action et se remettent tous octobre la
table ce genre décision ne pouvant en
aucun cas prise par quelques
décisionnaires politiques ou religieux
non avisé la plupart du temps lorsque
les enjeux patrimoniaux dont
l'importance est justement
c'est quoi ça c'est dit c'est un collège
qui a pris la décision du réaménagement
comment ça se passe et sont des votes
c'est
alors normalement les délais décision de
réaménagement se sont faites
après une longue concertation ait eu des
audits il ya eu des concertations
publiques des expertises et puis d il
faut rassembler des spécialistes aussi
de la conservation du patrimoine sur
autour de la table de façon à pouvoir
définir un cahier des charges très
précis
inquiétant c'est que c'est très bien
mais on parlerait de réaménagement
intérieur de la cathédrale notamment il
y aurait du mobilier contemporain
ce qui est étonnant c'est que c'est le
diocèse
qui est qui est en charge justement de
ce réaménagement intérieur dit
liturgique a priori plutôt conservateur
est ce que vous redoutez justement que
le mobilier ne soit remplacé par des
oeuvres plus contemporaines
alors c'est encore une fois là c'est
d'avoir exactement je connais pas le
dossier exactement mais le précisément
mais il est certain qu'à partir du
moment où on va changer même de même des
oeuvres intérieur qui concerne du
mobilier
éventuellement les circulation à
l'intérieur de la cathédrale d'après ce
que j'ai compris il faut absolument se
remettre tous autour de la table avec
des experts parce qu'il s'agit pas de
n'importe quel édifice
il y aura une réunion où justement le
jallarbiste un club où chacun veut même
même vie simple mobilier à l'intérieur
de cet édifice
comment sont répertoriés et font partie
de ce patrimoine il y aura une réunion
le 9 décembre pour trancher j'imagine la
question le diocèse réfutant tout cas
ces accusations de cathédrale qui
ressemblerait à disneyland le terme est
un peu un peu exagéré selon vous
alors que le terme oui en comparant
c'est à disneyland c'est peut-être un
petit peu un petit peu exagéré mais je
comprends je comprends l'inquiétude des
architectes qui ceux qui se sont
manifestés contre ce hausse cet éventuel
projet parce que parce que on re
privilégierait plutôt le tourisme plutôt
que plutôt que le lieu saint tel qu'il
est
oui parce que le synthé des fils bien
sûr il a il un atout touristique comment
considérable de toute façon et c'est
tout à fait louable comme je les dis de
vouloir comment améliorer son accès mais
le puits ces visites d'un point de vue
touristique mais il est essentiel de
bien considérer tout cet édifice dans
toute sa dimension patrimoniale autant
architectural qu'historique et
spirituelle également est-ce que vous en
tant qu'architecte vous constatez que
c'est une tendance la volonté à tout
prix d'imposer des choses nouvelles sur
des lieux chargés d'histoire
oui c'est pas forcément c'est pas
forcément nés face à partir du moment où
c'est bien fait il faut éviter oui
comment là comme ça a été dit peut-être
de façon exagérée il faudra voir le
prendre le projet précisément les faux
unités de 8 ans belle on nous dit alors
non merci beaucoup boris veltchev
d'avoir réagi justement à cette
rénovation intérieure de la cathédrale
dont le projet sera présenté je le
rappelle le 9 décembre prochain merci
beaucoup